do you want to play even more Japanese  games on your Nintendo switch you might  get your chance soon I'm Tony and this  is your localized GameSpot news updates  Seiken Densetsu 3 is the sequel to  Secret of Mana but it never released  outside of Japan not even on the Virtual  Console but the series official Japanese  Twitter account just released a teaser  of the game being played on the switch  thanks to the consoles region free  settings this might finally be your  chance to play the elusive action RPG if  it doesn't make its way stateside be  sure you're subscribed to GameSpot to be  the first to know when it gets an  official announcement speaking of the  Virtual Console we still don't know what  the plan is for implementing that  digital storefront on the switch  although Nintendo says we'll hear more  soon if you Japan a files need a fix in  the meantime then why not watch us watch  food Wars on the GameSpot Universe  channel  [Music]